and last but not least in this final
installment of collab week I am joined
by the superlative adjectives TomSka and
we will be collaborating through the
medium of song I would love to write a
song about Google+ but a song about how
we like Google+ that's how bad I like
the idea that we would write so
positively about Google+ but we would
just be we can make you make the subtext
of the song that we're doing in Karachi
because we have to yeah quite a fast and
happy soul it's quite sad here you
please why yeah boy though write a song
sometimes that takes all day how long
have we got now boy I need you know this
is the first time I ever tried to write
a song okay that's that so we're off to
a good start so it's all the metaphors
that I video voice is like Google being
the guy at the party who keeps like
changing the song but it's it's it's
Google's party so we kind of have to
just do it anyway who's that like I just
like to maybe the song is I think
something something's up it's something
fuss us so these are the big such a fuss
no that's stuff maybe we should mention
I'm a blackberry in the soil
hahahaha alright that's our first
complete line ok Google+ sorry Emma
blackery made such a fuss so we need to
now need to do it over us yeah this is
Charlie's channel so we just no fuss we
just don't cuss
where we something we won't come we
promise chairman Charlie we'll try not
to cuss okay that's how he changes we
didn't look for it but got it anyway
like it on nothing this side is here to
stay yeah that's it yeah right
yeah I did the Ori is the free rent life
now it seems like plus is here say hey I
like in Google Plus okay yeah so we're
come back in with Google+ ah we can have
to run Plus again dog like maybe they
would like weekly cases like the other
pronunciations are like Google+ Google
ad we promise that this site is really
not too bad there we go ah when we asked
for a plus-one please try to not get mad
yeah maybe we could say if one of the
features is red plus I'd be in your
circle it's so totally business kind of
rat I mean I went besides yeah yeah I
really get some of the metaphors though
of like yeah yeah like of like Google+
being a guy at a party have you the host
keep changing the Sun the parties in his
house so you just kind of play along
that's a long wait are you promised on
this site is really not too bad
Addison your circle so we won't be sad
so I haven't done anything about just
like give us a plus-one
know that I don't just start running
running out of funds please like me on
Google+ otherwise we run out money if
that's a message I really want to be
sending it does prime it does rhyme like
Robin Thicke didn't wanna be really
creepy but it did rhyme is out and give
us your plus one
yeah and know that will appreciate the
pond yes yes into a party and a host
keeps changing the song but when the pie
is hosted by Google good better keep
dancing along yeah that's fine
alright and down in order yeah maybe we
need to type them out like a ring by
ring made us
Google+ sorry Emma blackery made such a
fuss
we promised Tom and Charlie we'll try
not to cuss we didn't ask for it even
got in anyway but now it seems like
Google+ is here to stay it is Google Ads
we promise that this slide is really not
too bad
aniss in your circle so we won't be sad
help us out and give us your Plus Ones
and no we will appreciate them tons have
you ever been to a hottie and the host
keeps changing the song but when the
party's hosted by Google you better keep
dancing along Google us something
something something something guru about
a club week club week well now you've
just had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool
okie dokie thank you very much for
watching collab week and if you didn't
watch collab week here all the videos
that you missed and that's all
Tara tirar is British Wicca by just FYI